kedgwick sénat et le centre national du
livre présente livres et vous
[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans le livret vous
cette émission vous le savez accueille
des écrivains des artistes mais aussi
des personnalités politiques qui
viennent une fois n'est pas coutume vous
parler de littérature vous parler des
livres qui ont compté pour eux des
livres qu'ils ont apprécié les livres
qu'ils ont écrits même parfois et c'est
à chaque fois l'occasion d'interroger le
lien entre la littérature et l'exercice
politique
alors après nicolas sarkozy manuel valls
olivier besancenot
marlène schiappa et ségolène royal j'ai
le grand plaisir d'accueillir
aujourd'hui jean-luc mélenchon bonjour
bonjour bienvenue dans livres et vous
remercie vous connaissez bien cet
endroit je crois oui le palais en tout
cas j'étais sénateur donc je suis dans g
capable d'en percevoir la capacité d'en
de recrutement d'envoûtement ouais ce
palais en particulier c'est pas
l'assemblée nationale a aussi quelque
chose en elle mais quelque chose de plus
froids de plus cassants est ce que vous
êtes député aujourd'hui vous étiez plus
jeune sénateur et puis maintenant je
suis député et le le palais du
luxembourg à une magie notamment qui se
concentrent dans celui bibliothèque à
celle ci et puis à l'autre côté qui
donne sur le jardin du luxembourg où on
peut pour ceux qui aiment ça se s'offrir
des séances de mélancolie active de
première grandeur et de première beauté
et vous préférez être ici dans la
bibliothèque ou dans le jardin du
luxembourg
toutes les bibliothèques pourquoi la
présence des leafs avaient déjà parce
que je suis la bibliothèque aux voix le
jardin ce qui n'est pas le cas depuis le
jardin mais le le jardin du luxembourg
est un jardin à la française comme on
dit c'est à dire très géométrique
organisé il est plein de mystère aussi
un homme qu'il ya de quoi y faire il
passé de nombreuses heures j'ai passé de
nombreuses mais ce n'est pas la même
forme de le jardin une petite joie en
lui à les enfants les petits bateaux les
amours bon beaucoup de choses qui sont
piquante mais il n'y a pas ce côté
voluptueux de la présence des livres des
mille petites voix et 2
de ce qui peut se produire à tout moment
avec les livres c'est qu'il y en a un
qui vous saute dessus et rentrer dans
votre vie alors on va aller voir
ensemble ces listes qui vous ont sauté
dessus de voir de quelle manière ils
sont rentrés dans votre vie fait partie
des très rares personnalités politiques
françaises qui n'hésitait pas à parler
de littérature à y faire référence à
parler de votre goût pour les livres
alors que beaucoup de personnalités
explique que parler de lecture ou
littérature mais c'est une manière de se
situer au dessus du peuple sont
réticents à affirmer leur goût pour la
littérature alors qu'elles sont en
fonction c'est pas votre cas n'est ce
pas non et puis je crois qu'ils se
trompent les gens lille beaucoup toutes
sortes de choses mais il ne faut pas
hiérarchiser les cris c'est le conseil
que je donne après chacun fait comme il
veut mais il faut avoir
il faut être disponible se rendent
disponibles comme comme on l'est dans la
vie on peut l'être pour pour l'amour
pour la tendresse pour il faut se rendre
disponible et vous ne savez pas quel
livre un jour on va vous sautez sur les
genoux et tout d'un coup il dira mieux
que vous ne le feriez jamais ce que vous
aviez envie de dire et surtout ce que
vous aviez besoin de savoir c'est ça que
le le livre va éclairer tout d'un coup
donc je suis un jeu j'ai été prof pas
longtemps de france et j'ai toujours
refusé qu'on y est rare cheese
il a fait pas de grande littérature et
de petites alors après il ya vous savez
les usages sociaux alors dans les bons
usages
on reçoit les livres à l'école ou bien
on se l'est fait transmettre par de
doctes mettre moi je suis en partie dans
la littérature de gare
parce que j'ai beaucoup passer de temps
dans les gares du fait de mu active au
sens propre du terme
vous arrivez avec vos deux à l'offre
votre sac
et puis bon c'est plus fort que vous
vous entrez où il ya des livres et où il
ya des journaux et puis vous mettez à
choisir et voilà comment moi j'ai
découvert personne ne m'avait préparé à
ça j'ai découvert toute la littérature
américaine comme ça toute la science
fiction dakar alors je chasse j'assume
le caractère misérable de mes choix
c'est à dire que des fois c'était juste
la beauté de la première page de la
couverture de la photo c'est comme ça
que je me suis jetée dans le monde des
noix avec vannes oc jamais j'aurais lu
de la littérature de science fiction
mais voilà ce livre m'a sauté dessus et
j'en ai lu 700 après de science fiction
le pire et le meilleur à mes yeux
voilà mes mais par exemple lorsqu'une
cold wave bon moi j'étais un petit
garçon bien dressé par l'école française
donc j'étais à la littérature pendant
deux ans à la faculté avant comme eugène
de là parce qu'en disant non non la
littérature s'est pas posé trop l'esprit
de système bon mais j'ai fait ça et
j'aimais ça est bien mais personne ne
m'avait dit mais écoutez vous avez vu le
film la route du tabac bon ça m'avait
moyennement parler au ciné club
mais le livre mais le livre qui m'a
appris définitivement à écrire et à
parler autrement parce que comme c'est
l'arrêt du tabac parce que le diamant
que ça fait rire en la route du tabac
les tout montre sa sinistre
moi je trouve ça drôle c'est le récit
est en extériorité permanent tout le
temps absolu la littérature française la
littérature romanesque par de la
psychologie des personnes à 1 ce qu'ils
ressentent alors le sommet du top du top
c'est nathalie sarraute c'est depuis
l'intérieur du personnes avec plusieurs
discours en même temps ça a été une
espèce de parodie coldwell s'est
radicalement de l'extérieur et cette
expérience écologie c'est ça il y en a
pas c'est vous qui la créent ça en
lisant
mais vous voyez des personnages et alors
ce sont les personnages stupide de
coldwell donc il perçut attend à
rabâcher les mêmes formules inepte
bon mais tout d'un coup ils ont une
présence une force à cause de cette
extériorité comment vous inspirez vous
dites ça m'a beaucoup servi ensuite
pourra d'abord il faut gagner ma vie
parce que j'ai été journaliste pendant
deux ans est bon dans le journalisme
une phrase c'est sujet verbe complément
et il faut arriver à faire passer
quelque chose
et j'aimais bien cette contrainte elle
m'a complètement tout cas c'est la plume
et puis après elle m'a appris à parler
autrement quand vous faites une
intervention deux minutes dans un
hémicycle où chaque mot compte 1 et si
vous voulez y mettre un peu de grâce et
d'élégance ou de bons ce qui fait le
goût de l'art oratoire ce qu'ils ont
fait le piquant il faut savoir d'abord
manier la forme par ces travaux voilà
donc il ya ce surgissement de la
littérature et de l'extériorité dans la
description et dans le récit des
personnages qui me qu'il m'a beaucoup
construit mais je veux dire par hasard
absolue la route du tabac jeux les pages
les paluds parce que j'avais vu le film
c'est tout simplement parce que là la
première page m'avait plu génie tout
nuit voilà pour sa marque dans les bras
plus elle a un départ aussi pourquoi pas
j'étais assez je ne peux que ça
m'intéresse mais je savais je veux dire
que le nom mais parce que vous faites
une allusion grivois zombies j'assume
mais en réalité c'était parce que
c'était cole doit aller à partir de mon
j'ai lu tout ce qui passait de coldwell
est aussi bon après il ya le contraire
c'est
le bruit et la fureur
ouais enfin à shakespeare folle de l'air
voilà alors après il ya le contraire
tandis que j'agonise il faut venir tous
les personnages sont venues de
l'intérieur mais je n'ai pas j'ai pas
trouvé le même plaisir et la même source
d'hilarité qu'en lisant coldwell qui
vont n'a rien de drôle c'est que des
poutres viable minérale votre première
rencontre le premier livre qui a
vraiment compté pour vous on est bien
dans la littérature américaine c'est un
cadeau qu'on vous avez fait je crois
vous aviez offert les fleurs du mal et
on vous avait offert en retour
l'histoire de la révolution française
adolphe thiers oui alors c'est une
histoire d'amour évidemment un tiers non
non non je sais pas qui était à deux le
feu tirant plus quand on me l'a offert
non c'était une histoire d'amour avec
une jeune si on n'était pas bien vieux
alors eu des petits cadeaux comme ça et
moi je lui avais offert une fleur du mal
ce qui franchement et parce qu'il ya de
meilleur goût je trouve maintenant
rétrospectivement peut-être que ou
peut-être que je comptais la guider
d'avant voulu suggérer aux lui donner à
penser j'en sais rien en tout cas elle
m'a fait le cadeau le plus important de
ma vie
elle m'a offert que je pense qu'elle n'a
pas demandé à son père l'autorisation
les 8 ohms de l'histoire de la
révolution française par dole faîtière
et là bon c'est le bouleversement total
quoi les derniers sont les premiers et
moi j'étais un gamin de hlm pas bon la
geste héroïque du peuple français
bon voila j'ai été pris et ça ne m'a
plus lâchée de la vie et la savate
première rencontre avec la révolution
oui avec la révolution je savais je la
prenais à l'école mais c'est vraiment le
moment où je commence à comprendre et
puis après j'ai aussi urgent et j'en ai
lu je me sais combien l'histoire de la
révolution celle de jaurès évidemment
mais disons que celle-là a compté et
elle a compté de bien des manières parce
que quand j'ai réalisé qu'adolf hitler
était un réactionnaire abc sable avaaz
est surprenant par l'homme de gauche que
l'état ne pouvait savoir j'avais 14 ans
donc moi j'ai lu ça comme un roman et je
ne n'étais pas en état de normes qu'on
bon c'est après en relisant michelez là
vous êtes pris emporté nichent les non
plus n'aime pas robespierre
mais adolphe thiers est vraiment une
fripouille quoi parce que toulon il
traîne des personnages dans la boue
comme je le suis moi même aujourd'hui
donc alors il ya un personnage qui a
joué un rôle c'est antoine santerre il
est commandant de la garde nationale
et évidemment il des gouttes le
bourgeois parce que c'est le commandant
de la garde nationale c'est le peuple
la médaille comme disent certains et ce
personnage me fascine parce que tiers
l'insultent à longueur de pages chaque
fois qu'il est question de lui il met
cet alcoolique ce démagogue je sais pas
quoi en réalité il s'agissait de la
population du quartier du faubourg
saint-antoine qui était une population
ouvrière et il y avait là une entreprise
de papier peint qui avait été mitraillé
par les gars de royal et les prolos qui
était là il y avait pas beaucoup à
l'époque se sont bien rattrapés
parce que quand ils ont entendu dire le
12 et 13 juillet que les gens fûtés le
feu à toutes les barrières de paris
parce que c'est l'impôt le roi avait mis
la dernière barrière et là bas tout au
fond au bout de la rue du château landon
et il ya un bistrot maintenant là c'est
là c'est la plus belle c'est lé rôle art
honda et donc les gens mille feux tout
le long pour pu payer l'impôt parce
qu'il trouvait ça dégueulasse qu'on leur
met une barrière pour des plus ceux qui
sont dedans pay pay en octroie comment
ça mais nous avons toujours été là c'est
notre jardin il n'y a pas de ville ici
qu'est ce que vous voulez nous prendre
bref une affaire de gilet jaune de
l'époque ce type ont foutu le feu à tout
est alors les ouvriers ont tendance à 10
ah bon on en est là bas très bien nous
valait s'occuper de la bastille et c'est
comme ça que la décision de prendre la
bastille est prise par des ouvriers que
quand on fait la liste des gens qui ont
pris la bastille c'est très surprenant
il ya des ouvriers si bien que j'en
aurai le dit eh ben vous voyez vos
autres bourgeois même pour faire vos
révolutions il faut des prolétaires bon
quand même un abus de langage sur le
rôle de l'impôt dans la constitution du
peuple français ce sera sujet à la
discussion que nous aurons deuxième
partie d'émission avec gérard noiriel
qui va nous rejoindre
lui son savant pas moi moi ça c'est vous
qui le dites parce que justement si on
parle d'une autre lecture cas beaucoup
compté pour vous alors on sent votre
goût pour les romans historiques et pas
que les romands d'ailleurs même les
livres d'histoire et de révolution
française de lisier aussi de livres sur
philippe le bel de jean favier on y
viendra peut-être mais un livre un roman
qui a beaucoup compté pour vous qu'est
par roman américain que pas vraiment en
neurosciences fiction ce vendredi où la
vie sauvage de michel tournier pour ce
livre vous êtes en marquer alors là je
donne tout
autre registre pareil je tombé dessus
par hasard j'avais une assez mauvaise
impression de monsieur tournier parce
qu'on m'avait dit par seulement ça
compte pas beaucoup pour moi en
littérature l'étiquette politique de
celui qui écrit ses convictions je pense
bon balzac est un grand bourgeois il
scella la peinture la plus terrible de
la bourgeoisie c'est pas ça qui l'a fait
donc moi on m'avait dit oh tu comprends
c'est un vrai atout le dirai quand même
j'avais lu évidemment le robinson crusoé
initial qui est quand même un livre
malgré tout quand même colonialiste mais
pas qu'eux ne faut pas le réduire à ça
alors je prends ce vendredi et je suis
stupéfait par ce que michel tournier
fait un récit où sorte de résumé de ce
que sont les cycles à l'intérieur de la
vie d'un homme
alors je sais que c'est mal portée
aujourd'hui car si l'on pense que
quelque chose a un sens universel
il faudrait que ce soit range heures
mais ce n'est pas le cas il parle
spécifiquement des hommes quelque chose
qui est masculin il n'y a pas de femmes
dans le lit il n'y a pas d'enfant
lille qui est fécondé alors oui mais
enfin bon le genre féminin
pour moi ce n'est pas seulement
l'aptitude être fécondés c'est une
manière aussi un rapport au monde que
n'ont pas les hommes et l'histoire c'est
quand même ce robinson qui va échouer
sur une île partagée schultz une fois
dans notre vie et les objets sont
éparpillés sur le livre 28 ans je crois
sur l'île qui va essayer de construire
un bateau pour quitter l'île mais vas te
rendre compte que le bateau il a
construit beaucoup trop loin de la merde
on ne peut pas le mettre à l'eau c'est
une série de tentatives et des chèques
tout du calvaire et blanc sa vie
vendredi oui et vous vous lisez cette
rencontre vendredi qui est puis va venir
l'aider si le presque le début d'une
nouvelle fondation d'une autre société
vous dit en fait non vous n'y êtes pas
il racontera que ça raconte bien sûr ça
raconte alors je sais tu que je ne suis
pas l'attendait en bas de laisser la
parole à michel tournier lui-même
raconté cette rencontre entre robinson
sur l'île du levant passe toujours son
créateur on l'écouté vous nous direz
lorsque
robinson voit arriver ce jeune sauvage
il dit enfin voilà la justification de
tous c'est le sujet idéal
n'ai-je pas et il en fait le second tout
quand il est général c'est un simple
soldat
quand il est administrateur c'est son
valet quand il est prêtre c'est l'enfant
de choeur n'est ce pas et vendredi se
plie tant bien que mal à cette horde
absurde après tueur aux versions elle
lui a sauvé la vie
depuis n'y comprend rien parleriez n'y
comprend rien et puis sous cette souche
est sous cette apparente soumission il
ya une révolte malgré lui mais je dois
vendre y fait des catastrophes
soumission révolte alors c'était le 5
avril 1967 à michel tournay qui
s'exprime c'est une archive il n'a
l'auteur du livre à une présentation
manière de présenter son roman disons de
façon politique
or vous ça ce qui est très intéressant
parce qu on vous entend beaucoup parler
de soumission et de révolte soumission
comme étant le lieu et la justification
d'une grève elle vous dit non c'est une
histoire d'hommes moi je lis je le gens
parlent comme je lui le moment où ce
livre m'a sauté sur les genoux il est
arrivé dans ma vie à un moment où
j'avais besoin des éclaircissements qui
m'a apporté
il m'a montré que nous sommes tous deux
débarqués sur une île déserte après
avoir perdu la moitié de nos biens c'est
un naufrage
comme tout le monde
une relation amoureuse qui explose avec
tout le monde qu'ils ont
tout explose tout part en morceaux mais
vous le savez bien il ya plein de gens
qui m'entendent et qu'ils le savent
quelques misérables objets auxquels on
se raccroche mais en même temps que l'on
rejette bref et le moment où l'on fuit
cet ordre ancien parce que la nostalgie
est trop forte
la douleur est trop grande et alors
robinson course dans une espèce
d'eau chaude tiédasse de bouillasse des
laïcs et cochons et il reste des
journées entières dans la fumée des
instincts les plus élémentaires
et puis un jour il se dit mais je vais
mourir si je continue à me laisser aller
comme ça qui sait paris mais ça et puis
il sort de la pop il va se lavait
ramasse tout ce qui traîne sur la plage
ils organisent la grotte que machin le
truc toc toc toc tout est organisé à la
clé toussaint alain il est tout seul et
les jours ils les conti les bd encore
dans l'arbre ils organisent la
plantation tout ça tout marche du feu de
dieu
et ça y est la vie revenue en ordre mais
la vie en ordre même en ordre la vie
sans amour
il tourne en rond dacquois et puis
arrive vendredi alors évidemment on peut
l'analyser la relation dominant-dominé
moi je veux pas ça du tout comme ça
vendredi fiche la pagaille vendredi est
l'incarnation du désordre que l'amour
introduit dans la vie d'un homme
organiser méthodiquement tout est
planifié puis arrive quelqu'un paquin a
rien à faire de ces plantations de ces
interdits de ses trucs et de de sottises
en sottise il finit par jeter la pipe
dans la poudrière tout exploser le monde
en ordre de robinson est détruit et tous
les deux vont partir faire quelque chose
d'extravagant mais qui est le propre de
la relation amoureuse qui est de courir
après un book pour le découper et en
faire un cerf-volant qui fait de la
musique c'est à dire quelque chose qui
ne sert strictement à rien sinon à
s'émerveiller et moi je les lui comme ça
le moment solaire de la vie est bien
tous les hommes rencontrent leur
naufrage leurs sous leurs ordres leur
nouvelle explosion et le moment solaire
est évidemment il fallait que ça
s'arrête cette histoire
et à la fin arrivés en bateau à l'autre
il a tellement attendu ça enfin un
bateau donc le premier qui courent
dessus c'est vendredi quant à une
affiche aussi de robinson et qui finit
par disparaître dans le bateau et aura
robinson est soignée tout ça et puis on
leur âge et on lui donne un miroir et à
ce moment-là il réalise qu'il a vieilli
qu'il découvre son visage n'avait pas vu
son reflet depuis plus de 28 ans et
alors il voit le temps qui a passé sur
lui et le rapport à nous-mêmes qui
occupons plusieurs corps différent de
notre vie qui sommes plusieurs personnes
différentes à ce moment-là lui surgi les
clac à la figure d'un seul coup et nous
avons un moment où nous rencontrons
notre histoire c'est à dire le beau mao
nous réalisons que nous avons été
plusieurs personnes et que nous sommes à
la recherche de continuité qui ne
justifie à nos propres yeux
mais voilà comment j'ai lu le je le
recommande à tous les hommes que qui
sont mes amis je leur dis tu dois je
pense qu'il est plus universel que on
peut tu vas me sens d'avoir une lecture
bien attraper les gens morts oui mais
bien sûr mais passer d'un naufrage à une
conception plus solaire de l'existant ça
nous est tous arrivé
justement si vous vous identifier quel
est le naufrage pour vous quelle était
la période solaire mais il y en a eu
plein c'est cyclique
le naufrage c'est quand une amour prend
fin et vous n'avez pas souhaité cette
fin tout le monde vit ça une fois dans
sa vie
je m'empresse d'informer tous ceux qui
ne l'écoutent et qui n'ont pas connu ça
ça va leur arriver
ça peut être des moments de la vie où
tout d'un coup des certitudes explose
vous ne croyez plus du tout à ce que
vous avez cru jusque là pas soumis
qu'aux pourquoi vous faites l'objet
d'une perquisition c'est un naufrage
ouais c'est l'équivalent du naufrage
parce qu'à ce moment-là s'effondre en
moi une forme de confiance que j'avais
malgré tout quoi de confiance oui dans
les institutions mon pays je j'étais
sommes capables de faire des phrases
j'ai confiance dans la justice de mon
pays je
l'arrêté délégué ce qui se passe non pas
du tout bien sûr que non bien sûr quand
on sait pas légal de surgir sans
autorisation préalable
dans le cadre d'une enquête préliminaire
chez quelqu'un armés avec des n'avait
pas de mandat
non si il y avait mais vous verrez que
c'était illégal
enfin peu importe là nous sommes dans le
roman d'accord c'est une explosion et
des choses qui tombent deux mois comme
du bois mort tout d'un coup je
m'apercevrai je n'y crois plus et me
voilà revenu quasiment à mes 20 ans
quand j'étais un militant
révolutionnaire ou en effet je pensais
que tout ça c'était les attributs de la
société bourgeoise et je le combattrai
globalement fin en esprit là mais était
prendre d'assaut n'est un tribunal ni
une qu'à leur nie pas que ce soir mais
c'est pour dire et et a donc il faut
apprendre à vivre sans cette cet
ensemble de certitudes rassurantes et
plus que jamais la société m'apparaît
dans sa fragilité dans dans le fait
qu'elle repose entièrement sur le
consentement à l'ordre aux usages qui
nous unissent l'un à l'autre dans toutes
les circonstances et je crois que
peut-être que ça me rend plus
responsable de ma propre existence comme
comme l'a été à ce moment-là robinson
qui lui a eu le a fait le mauvais choix
et qu'on tout de suite se foutent dans
la bouillasse et les turpitudes et au
delà cette phase où on dira jamais assez
alors on cherche en soi ans qu'on se
sent coupable parce que tout ce truc est
fait pour boire on ne peut pas blanc
vous institut coupable et alors vous
vous sentez vous responsable en tout cas
de votre propre existence qu un peu
différent non non non non non non mais
quand une machinerie destiné à vous
rendre coupable parce que tout le monde
se sent coupable sans savoir de quoi
vous savez c'est le fameux procès 1
voilà de grève car voilà et on l'accuse
il ne sait pas de quoi mais il doit
aller au tribunal exactement pourquoi
moi je ne savais pas de quoi j'étais
accusé parce que ce sont des
dénonciations mais moi j'ai jamais que
d'avoir ce n'est pas l'attaqué des semis
mais imaginez vous mes jeunes collègues
qui eux savaient même pas cette année
de joseph k c'est ça non mais plutôt de
robinson ça me plaît plus que kafka bon
ces sinistres moi je ne suis pas au
point très drôle sur quatre est beaucoup
plus drôle que ce qu'on croyait plus
drôle que tourner en tout cas j'aimerais
vous parler avec tellement d'amour de
l'amour des romans d'amour mais vous
avez écrit des livres pourquoi est ce
que vous n'avez jamais écrit deux romans
d'amener une fois j'ai dit saluer
kerharo monde à moins de deux jours
après m'ont dit oui mais alors j'ai
essayé une fois et je me suis aperçu
qu'on n'arrive pas à parler d'amour
davantage qu'on arrive à parler du
plaisir on peut parler du désamour c'est
à dire on peut décrire le processus du
désamour
comment quelqu'un vous tombe du coeur il
faut bien s'y supposée à en inventer une
relation amoureuse et c'est pas vous qui
avez choisi de la finir est elle finie
et donc c'est très douloureux et vous ne
pouvez pas vous en sortir tant que vous
ne vous êtes pas fâché c'est ça n'existe
pas les sorties il faut se cacher à sa
dure pas longtemps mais il faut et à ce
moment-là politique enfin vous vous
comprenez les mécanismes du désamour
qu'est ce que vous devez faire tomber
pour que sa cuisine moi donc je me suis
aperçu que ça je saurai éventuellement
l'écrire mais comment
le sens contraire séparer regarder le
plaisir j'ai mis mille fois les genres
défi que j'ai dit allez explique raconté
personnes trouvent les mots la douleur
on a des dizaines de d'image de
comparaison d' je pense que il y a une
forme d'accomplissement qui confine à
l'accès au néant dans l'amour et dans le
plaisir et c'est pas pour rien qu'on
appelle la jouissance sexuelle la petite
mort parce que c'est une façon de passer
dans autre chose qu'on ne peut plus nous
mais ce qu'on ne peut pas nommer existe
mais ne peut pas entrer dans le monde
des vivants c'est comme ça et pourtant
c'est ça qui vous intéressent aussi
juste avant d'accueillir monsieur
noiriel j'aimerais vous entendre dire en
quelques mots pourquoi ce goût vous
l'avez évoqué très rapidement pour la
science fiction particulier pour razim
of isaac asimov parce que asie meuf par
là on est vraiment dans l'invention d'un
autre ouais parce que c'est un auteur
très puissant au sens où quand je les ai
découverts art c'est pas aujourd'hui
c'était dans les années 70 imaginez des
robots une des règles éthiques de la
robotique
c'était extraordinaire parce qu'il y
avait des paradoxes à partir de
principes simples
c'était des principaux taux
organisateurs très simple à 2 ou 3 3 ou
4 règles me rappelle plus et puis à
partir de là tout le foisonnement la
complexité de la vie s'organise et donc
j'ai adoré azim up et après il y avait
une prétention dans le cycle fondation
et empire il avait inventé un personnage
hari seldon qui a inventé la
psychohistoire donc il prévoit tout ils
organisent tout moi j'adorais jeu
j'avais 22 23 ans
plus récemment alors dedans il y a
logram voilà il avait enregistré et
quand on a fait la campagne de 2010 est
des présidentielles j'étais vraiment
travailler part ça je dit écoutez on va
trouver ça ça existe j'en suis sûr on
doit savoir le faire bon et je découvre
que je crois qu'en premier ministre
indien ait fait ça peut alors me direz
d'accord mais faut que tu acceptes de
parler dans une boîte avec du tissu et
regardons ça moi je sais pas le faire il
ya une faute des gens devant moi sinon
je sais pas le faire alors on a cherché
on a trouvé entreprises qui savaient le
faire et puis et on l'a fait on sait à
la fois amusé et on a inventé quelque
chose car en politique ça n'existait pas
c'est à une première mondiale en
discours et qui retransmis en hologramme
c'est pas du tout pour évidemment il ya
toujours des méchancetés qui se dit
c'est pas parce que j'étais aux espèces
de célébration personnel cgt comme un
gosse devant faut se rendre compte que
moi j'ai adoré la conquête de l'espace
non plus grands héros c'est gagarine
comme il est plus facile de vivre comme
les romans de science-fiction que comme
les romans d'amour ça c'est une bonne
leçon claire notamment un ouvrage qui a
beaucoup fait parler de lui à l'époque
ce en 2014 l'ère du peuple et
l'importance du peuple pour vous elle
n'est pas simplement politique c'est
aussi le terme même de peuple sur lequel
vous pouvez dire l'enjeu
voilà qu'on s'arrête et qu'on va
continuer en parler
après avoir accueilli gérard noiriel qui
vient nous rejoindre pour paraître une
histoire populaire de la france estime m
[Musique]
bonjour gérard noiriel bonjour merci de
nous rejoindre et c'est sur le plateau
de livres et vous sur vos habitudes
vous êtes directeur d'études à l'ehess
usa vous avez trouvé travaillé sur
l'histoire de la classe ouvrière
notamment et vous fait paraître une
histoire populaire de la france de la
guerre de cent ans à nos jours aux
éditions agone alors on va revenir sur
l'histoire populaire je parlais à
l'instant deux peuples avec jean luc
mélenchon un mot là-dessus quand même
sur le peuple est ce qu'on en a parlé
finalement l'ère du peuple c'est le
titre du livre que vous avez écrit en
2014 vous aviez voulu proposer une
nouvelle conception de la france en
remettant le mot du peuple en son centre
aujourd'hui on ne parle que de sein du
mériot la théorie c'était surtout un
travail théorique moi je n'ai pas la
puissance et la profondeur scientifique
de nos réelles c'était pas mon sujet mon
sujet c'est de dire les révolutions
notre époque sont des révolutions
citoyennes
ce n'est pas la même chose qu'une
révolution socialiste à contient
d'autres choses elles sont le fait d'un
acteur nouveau dans l'histoire qui
s'appelle le peuple ce qui veut dire que
le move up aujourd'hui ne désigne pas le
même peuple celui du 20e du xviiie du ou
du xviie siècle c'est le peuple de
l'humanité qui a passé deux milliards
d'individus à cette bientôt à 10 qui vit
tous regroupés au même endroit dans
d'immenses d'ensemble qui fabrique que
de l'interdépendance qui sont des
ensembles urbains et à partir de là ça
décrit un nouvel individu qui surgit
dans l'histoire du fait de ce collectif
par ces chaînes d'interdépendance c'est
le citoyen qui veut s'approprier la
maîtrise de sa propre vie une fois qu'on
avait fait cette rupture
on va commencer à travailler sur qu'est
ce que le peuple sénèque
cet ensemble d'êtres humains qui pour
produire et reproduire leur existence
doivent accéder au réseau alors les
réseaux eau potable électricité la rue
la santé et l'éducation tout et en
réseau que c'est tout le monde le pas de
stream c'est le quasiment la totalité de
la population mais elle est traversée
par un conflit parce que certains
possèdent et les autres ne possède rien
et ce qui précède font aussi partie du
peuple
de la population mais pas du peuple car
voilà la distinction le peuple est un
sujet politique
il se constitue en tant qu'acteur
politique par les revendications qu'il
présente et qu'il va soutenir forcément
contre qui contre cette minorité qui
veut lui interdire l'accès au réseau ou
le lui faire payer de manière abusive et
il va essayer de tout s'approprier tout
le temps même l'endroit où ils habitent
en disant ben sans aucun rapport avec la
valeur d'usagé d'un appartement il va
avoir une valeur différente sur le coeur
que ce sont les dominer ce sont les
dominés 2 les gens obligés d'accéder au
réseau collectif pour produire et
reproduire leur existence pardon je
termine juste sur ce point parce qu'il a
une grande importance dans la surface
des populismes ça n'a rien à voir avec
la science lorsque je raconte c'est de
la politique dans ceux qui se disent
populiste moi je ne me dis pas populiste
pour une raison populiste sais que je
devrai me battre pour le mot or dans les
stratégies police on se bat pas pour les
mots on met des mots en circulation et
on les a investis du sens qu'on veut y
mettez par exemple le mot gauche est
complètement pourri jusqu'à la moelle
alors c'est la plus belle idée du monde
pourquoi parce qu'il a été tellement
déprécier que vous passez votre temps à
expliquer en quoi vous êtes de gauche
mais pas comme l'autre et a donc dans
l'idée de gauche dans l'idée de peuple
dans dans les populistes qui existe
aujourd'hui
moi j'appartiens à l'école matérialise
c'est à dire que nous décrivons le
peuple par son rapport physique concret
à l'accès au réseau alors les gilet
jaune ça a été le l'explosion de la
vérification de la thèse bon parce que
ça met en jeu d'abord la visibilité
samedi en jeu cette distinction entre
peuples population est une histoire
populaire de la france c'est l'histoire
du peuple de la population préhistoire
du populaire donc c'est la banque
populaire le mot le mot populaire pour
moi il ya différentes définitions fait
une histoire populaire c'est d'abord
qu'on veut s'adresser à un public plus
large que celui des spécialistes donc à
des enjeux d'écriture de justement se
rapprocher de l'écriture littéraire de
trouver des exemples qu'elle les gens
puissent s'identifier etc
et puis a effectivement l'objet même de
que son entend par populaire et donc
pour moi je ne
limite pas le populaire aux classes
populaires c'est pour moi le populaire
c'est une relation qui implique
effectivement les dominants et les
dominés ce que vous regardez dans
l'histoire les termes mêmes vous parliez
tout à l'heure à juste titre de l'enjeu
des mots comment les mots évoluent selon
les définitions que données et a
toujours le rôle des élites de ceux qui
manient le langage qui maîtrisent les
représentations joue un rôle très
important
y compris dans l'image que les dominés
se font de même mais c'est pour ça que
j'ai construit ce livre autour de cette
relation
c'était une mais aussi une manière de
montrer parce que beaucoup l'oublient
aujourd'hui tout ce qu'apporte les
classes populaires même dans l'évolution
des élites et des dominants c'est une
dialectique voilà donc j'ai renoué un
peu avec un principe de de marx sur la
dialectique de la lutte des classes mais
en l'enrichissant par des apports qui
viennent des sciences sociales vous
d'été la naissance du peuple à la guerre
de cent ans
parce que je pense que c'est l'état
surtout dans un pays comme la france où
l'état à jouer toujours un rôle
extrêmement important c'est la mise en
place j'allais dire quasi définitive de
l'état royal à l'époque à l'époque de
jeanne d'arc donc de aussi de charles
vii qui crée du lien c'est à dire c'est
à ce moment là qu'on passe d'une
population un peuple et un population
c'est des individus qui sont côte à côte
sera terry pas un peuple il faut qu'il
ya un lien et ce lien c'est un lien
souvent de voilà le lien de souveraineté
en appel c'est à dire de suggestions au
départ après des sujets deviendront
citoyens et dans cette suggestion
évidemment il y a des rapports de
domination mais aussi il ya des
résistances
c'est très important ce convoi de
dix-sept époque là les luttes anti
fiscal contre les injustices fiscales
apparaîtrait que les murs et fiscales
sont à l'origine de la naissance du
peuple en fruits en tant que forces
mobilisées oui et de contestant les
injustices c'est à ce moment là que ça
apparaît dans le cas français avec
philippe le bel notamment nourri autant
ballon voilà philippe lebel s'est un
petit peu là un peu avancé un peu la la
la la la naissance de l'état mme avec
une fragilité puisque mon c'est qu'au
moment de la guerre de cent ans
yahia
un risque de disparition au quasiment de
monarchie à quel moment la guerre de
cent ans
c 'est de 13/100 jusque voilà le début
du xvème siècle enfin il ya certains
parlent même de la guerre de 300 enfants
pas entrer dans les détails mais c'est 7
ce qui achève le moyen-âge avec la
grande crise aussi vous savez de cette
période-là la peste noire où la moitié
de la population européenne disparaisse
même en fête la naissance du peuple
c'est le moment où une certaine partie
de la population d'un remettre en
question l'imposition ça oui c'est ça
enfin il ya différentes dimensions les
saisir mais il aura tout d'abord qui
sous il a d'abord fallu qu'ils y soient
soumis c'est à dire que l'on laurent
seigne de l'extérieur nous et qu'il est
bien de l'extérieur qu'ils forment un
tout en forme tous deux personnes qui
sont dans l'indépendant de tel ou tel
seigneur de tel ou tel
et à ce moment là la discussion va
commencer dirai pourquoi moi et pourquoi
je paye ça et pourquoi lui n'en fait pas
autant et ainsi de suite à dire que le
on devient sujet politique le sujet qui
arrive sur la table c'est de la
politique c'est pas juste moi même ma
famille de masse que j'aurai des pommes
de terre dans mon champ ou pas tout d'un
coup j'ai appartient à un ensemble plus
plus long c'est à dire que quand se
constitue de manière visible les réseaux
d'interdépendance entre les âmes est
exactement ce qu est la science des
réseaux politiques sans les mêmes
raisons qui ont conduit les il est jeune
dans la rue aujourd'hui une très longue
durée il ya des très grandes différences
pour ça moi j'ai récusé le terme de
jacques rives des cakes péjoratif
y aura-t-il de la thur les gagnants qui
gagnent oui c'est ça c'est froissart
l'historiographe des rois qui a désigné
ses luttes paysannes comme étant des
jacqueries des sauvages qui qui dit les
tuer les ces pauvres noble et c'est donc
le terme est resté et on ne peut pas
l'utiliser aujourd'hui pour désigner le
vous définissez ce qu'on y retrouve un
mouvement du peuple interdépendants qui
vient lutter contre une alors une
imposition la souris la suppression du
fisc rares exemples de taxation il ya
des points communs donc déjà la lutte
toi dignité c'est extrêmement important
la logique symbolique ce très important
le peuple inventent et imaginent des
choses qui aurait pensé
peut-être vous ou je ne sais pas mais
cette imagerie du gilet du gilet jaune
d'ailleurs enfin moi je suis à dire que
c'est vrai que j'ai pas vu beaucoup de
monde trouver un sens subversif à cette
notion extrêmement administrative qui
concerne l à la sécurité routière la
visibilité dont la visite est retourné
en symboles administratifs pour en faire
un symbole de lutte et qui correspond
bien à nos revendications c'est à dire
nous sommes au bord de la route on nous
a laissés tomber
et voilà on appelle à l'aide et puis en
même temps il ya le côté visible du
gilet dans toute l'histoire il ya des ya
des moments symboliques comme ça le
principal problème des classes dominées
c'est leur visibilité
oui je regarde la télévision il ya des
critiques qui sont faites par le csa une
enquête du csa convoi 2 3 % d'ouvriers
et 70 % de cadres ça n'a rien à voir
avec la composition réelle de la société
le gilet jaune est un moment de
visibilité parce que la visibilité au
siècle de l'image des émissions si
beaucoup des médias justement
autre sujet en attendant la vigie maison
et le zoo
en même temps même bien de symboles
communs mais là où on retrouve quand
même des constances et le mépris des
dominants pour les autres parce que on
va prendre des exemples bien lointains
comme ça ça fâchera personne mais la
révolte etienne marcel alors là c'est
charles 5
oui c'est le début et quand on ressent
cette rencontre alors bon etienne marcel
précisé marc à paris déclenché une
révolution d'abord pour contrôler le bon
usage de l'argent du fait le roi
d'accord et commence par tuer les grands
seigneurs enfin on va passer les détails
là dessus ça passe aux ouvriers aux
bourgeois de la ville des bourgeois aux
ouvriers les ouvriers des villes sont
tout à fait d'accord avec ça ils
s'expliquent d'une ville à l'autre comme
aujourd'hui on va faire si on va par là
vous aussi oui on le fait on le fait et
puis tout le monde est bien d'accord
jusqu'au moment où arrivent les paysans
alors la terminer tout le monde sera mis
d'accord c'est pas possible il faut
arrêter ça tout de suite parce que ces
gens là ce sont des brutes et des
barbares on ne peut pas parler avec eux
on peut rien faire avec eux donc et à un
moment où l'élite s'est attrapé la la la
classe moyenne
d'une certaine manière n'ouvriers des
villes des corporations c'est un peu une
classe moyenne par rapport aux nobles et
1 et à la bourgeoisie pour la mettre
avec soi vous dire non à jeddah correct
on a passé violences passées après on
retrouve toujours les mêmes samse on
dira qu'il ya aussi une crac qui
allaient quand les classes populaires
les vraiment les plus modestes les
élites essaye de les mobiliser parce
qu'ils ont besoin de leur force
collective pourrait réussir leurs
entreprises mais après une fois qu'à
ceux cette violence populaire qui éclate
il ya une peur et les élites se soudent
c'est aussi résultats de la fronde en
fin de toute une série d bien dans votre
livre une lecture un peu plus subtil
qu'une bipartition entre d'un côté le
peuple et de l'autre les élytres est
elle utile parce que finalement nous
sommes en train aujourd'hui parler de ce
que vous appelez les ouvriers le peuple
certes nous sommes autour de cette table
on n'est pas exigé les jeunes en train
de manifester tous ceux qui ne font pas
partie du peuple tel que vous l'entendez
sont pas forcément de méchants d'élite
qui manipule le peuple donc toute façon
il y en a pour tradition tradition mais
attendez vous
attendez je trouve je parle tellement
tellement frappant que vous éprouviez le
besoin de ça mais non parce qu'on essaie
de dans la nuance est bien sûr mais la
nuance c'est la gent 5 pour méthode
historique ne va pas fermer radier qui
est des élites qui ont tous qui domine
les autres les méprise les insultes on
est loin de moi l'idée d'avoir l'accord
voulu dire si ce mot si on vous précise
très intéressant dans votre lit gérard
noiriel c'est vous montrer le lien entre
les luttes sociales et la violence vous
dit que finalement la violence a
toujours été de mise qui a pas du tout
une escalade de la violence et même
encore aujourd'hui on le dit il ya eu
plusieurs morts
clay gilet jaune plus de 1000 blessés
que ce soit lors des accidents ou des
choses un peu plus tragique ce lien
entre les deux êtres très intéressant
parce qu'aujourd'hui on a envie de
dénoncer ces violences la wii alors
alors qu'en fait que faut-il dire
exemple la violence globalement et leur
recul moi je dis que les gens de notre
génération sa première génération depuis
x mais marc jeanne d'arc qui n'a pas
connu la guerre je vais dire autrement
si vous prenez les gens de plus de 55
ans avait toujours connu vécu la guerre
on est on est dans un recul de cette
violence là un j'entends de la violence
militaire etc
mais effectivement la violence et une
dimension de de l'histoire et qui
souvent est particulièrement forte comme
les les groupes ne sont pas intégrés cc
voit la cceu voilà n'ont pas les moyens
d'où l'importance de la culture aussi de
la littérature d'accès à les critiques
bah oui parce que c'est une manière de
6-2-2 les journées très très violent oui
oui mais globalement on voit très bien
canton historiquement le recul de la
violence dans les luttes sociales qui
est liée aussi aux progrès de la culture
écrite la construction du mouvement
ouvrier qui passe par des formes de
représentations qui sont liées aux
journaux qui sont liées à des formes
plus pacifique et au fait il y avait des
espaces de dialogue et négocié des
espaces qu'ils ont été absolument tout
détruit en derrière l'autre par le
néolibéralisme la violence elle est
toujours dans l'histoire pour ma part je
je ne suis pas partisan mais pour des
raisons je mets la mort à l'insurrection
citoyenne
oui mais l'insurrection citoyenne c'est
pas forcément une opération de violentes
ou on casse on brûle et on pille
je sais pas c'est pas ma ligne ça donc à
moins qu'elle ferme elle prend là elle
peut prendre toutes sortes de formes
c'est le blocage c'est le vote le vote
l'abstention
en ce moment nous sommes en pleine
insurrection citoyenne à chaque élection
les des proportions gigantesques de gens
qui disent je vais pas bon donc sa
plainte d'un citoyen de faisans de
voitures en effet nommé paradoxal les
gens devraient obéir et n'obéissent pas
bon mais la violence a tous moi pourquoi
je ne suis pas partisan de la violence
c'est pas pour des raisons morales même
si le poids de la morale à son jeu pour
des raisons de stratégie
la violence nous isole la violence
dispersent dans nos forces
moi j'ai toujours dit à mes amis les
bonnes révolution c'est celle où venait
qu'à poussette et votre gosse dedans
parce ça veut dire tout le monde est là
c'est que sinon vous divisez vous
séparer et vous servez l'ennemi pas
c'est trop facile pour le dominant de
revenir ils ont toujours fait après la
commune de paris ils rappliquent tous
pour dire ah oui c'était bien
orange est trop violent ils ont fusillé
trente deux mille personnes ça c'est pas
violent mais qu'on ait fusil et quatre
évêques
ah oui ça c'était avant c'est justement
mais dans l'histoire aussi il ya cette
violence mais aussi le l'imagination
créatrice des classes populaires les
formes de contestation le rire
carnavalesque par exemple qu'on trouve à
l'a décrite formidablement bien chez
rabelais ou après dont le livre de
martin etc
c'est des choses très importantes à gg
rappelé ah oui oui les artistes des
artistes voilà des artistes la culture
populaire dans sa diversité
parce que je trouve ça manque un peu
aujourd'hui dans le mouvement des gilets
jaunes et que pour donner de la
visibilité
si les artistes soutenait da fortage
dirait le mouvement il y aura peut-être
une culture du rond-point à inventer
puisant dans ses traditions que je
décris dans plusieurs chapitres de mon
livre je pense que voilà il y aurait des
ressources qui permettraient aussi
d'élargir le mouvement au delà de 200
celle des cercles actuelle mais là il
faut s'expliquer la haine des dominants
professeur il faut il faut on ne peut
pas passer à côté on peut pas passer à
côté pourquoi les riches style comme ça
pourquoi vous voyez vous une un texte
signé par 150 personnes
monsieur bernard henri lévy monsieur
hanouna et cetera pour dire calmez vous
rentrez à la maison il faut arrêter
quelle est cette peur pourquoi ils sont
comme ça de dire calmez-vous ça veut pas
dire qu'il est à heath bell mais on sait
lire les textes quand même oui mais là
une manière de dire aux gens vous aviez
des brutes et donc calmez-vous un
calmez-vous on veut bien vous écouter
mais rentre à la maison
en tout cas vous avez fait publier une
tribune dans le monde gérard noiriel dix
ans les gilets jaunes replace la
question sociale au centre du jeu
politique le dire que la question
sociale
c'est justement la question sociale
c'est des questions qui sont posées par
héberger les jaunards longueur de
journée l'ailé d injustice par rapport à
l'impôt le problème de la reconnaissance
pour les les gens qui sont méprisés
l'accès à la parole la citoyenneté
direct tout ça et puis la définition
d'un peuple justement qui rompt avec
comme une longue période il y avait un
fractionnement en fait les choses vous
savez les les les lutte identitaire etc
si on les sépare de la question sociale
on divise le peuple aussi qu'est ce que
ça veut dire
ben si vous voulez vous avez dans
l'histoire lors des formes de 2,2 pour
casser les mouvements sociaux très
souvent il ya eu les dominant utilisé
les différences d'origine où les
différents soyez donc pour ce qu'on a
appelé la rationaliser la racialisation
dans l'histoire calais oui enfin ce mot
il est récent donc ya pas beaucoup de
sens historiquement mais je veux dire
voilà d'aider des usages de 2,2
d'éléments de qui font partie des
critères de définition des personnes
mais qui sont isolées du reste et qui
contribue à séparer les gens parce qu'on
a appelé la rationalisation dans l'
empire colonial c'est ça il ya des gens
aux antilles je le montre dans un des
chapitres y avait beaucoup de points
communs et qu'on a dit viser à part
disant voilà blanc noir et c'est donc
ces questions là qui sont très
importants tout ça j'ai beaucoup
travaillé sur l'histoire des migrations
donc tout ça c'est très important
mais voilà il ya une dimension sociale
qu'il faut remettre à ceux ci ont la
refoule d'une manière ou une autre elle
avait largement effacé généraux chez
joly
alors à la pratique politique avec j'ai
bon d'accord ça sur la question comment
fais tu voulais présenter cette classe
populaire fait il représentait cette
classe sociale passe à des plantes et
les moments dans l'histoire sont
différents quand la température monte
sociales et politiques l'information
circule beaucoup plus rapidement les
mécanismes d'auto organisation sont
prêts ample et d'auto représentation on
peut pas on peut pas traiter de la même
manière l'objet révolution en mouvement
ou insurrection et la vie politique
ordinaire donc c'est des règles et que
fait-on vous vous êtes un homme
politique comme en ville comment faites
vous pour apporter votre soutien ça
donnait l'impression de récupérer ce qui
se passe qui contient déjà pascal
pommier qui s'approprie le mouvement le
rabougri où il ya beaucoup de personnes
qu'il ya des tentatives d'appropriation
il en a beaucoup entendu comme un nom il
ya eu beaucoup de la part pardon ne sera
pas vous plaire mais obligé de le dire
je vais d'emprunter à lui 1 ce qui l'a
très bien écrit dans son interview dans
le monde il dit c'est la lutte
permanente entre les politiques qui
veulent être les représentants du peuple
et les médias qui prétendent être les
seuls autorisés à parler en son nom
donc tout in helmand comme vous allez
sur un plateau aujourd'hui il ya une
figure imposée c'est le moment le
journaliste se tourner vers les gets des
jaunes est dit n'est ce pas vous ne
voulez pas être récupérés mais s'il ya
aussi d'élus de parmi le la les systèmes
de représentations collectives des
compétitions mais c'est la question la
représentation quand même une question
historique fondamentale elle se pose en
1789 contre kurt à la manière de faire
de la politique justement ici c'est
peut-être le signe qu'il ya la
représentativité en politique à temps
mais elle a atteint ses limites parce
que ce système est absurde c'est la
monarchie présidentielle et ça dégouline
là pour le coup car oui c'est la
cinquième année mais c'est pas le
premier c'est l'institution qui fait ça
et c est reparti à mon avis mais c'est
pas seulement savent c'est qu'on a
quelque chose à inventer il faut chaque
génération un truc sur les sur les bras
qu'il faut qu'elle règle nous avons
besoin de stabilité des institutions et
nous avons besoin face à un peuple est
plus éduqués qui l'a jamais été de samy
plus sachant plus connaissant de lui
donner une capacité d'intervention
permanente comme on fait les deux c'est
ça la difficulté
nous on a inventé un truc on a sorti le
référendum vous
c'est du populaire notamment révocatoire
bons d'achat vaut ce que ça vaut vous
nous les enfants pour dire ben faisons
des référendum révocatoire comme ça
quand vous dites celui là là celle-là
alors pas pourquoi elle est là et pour
quoi elle parle en notre nom bon alors
il faut x signataires et puis on vote
pour savoir si elle reste ou si elle par
ses frères ou que ce soit le président
de la république et ceux d'aujourd'hui
justement j'essaye de montrer dans ce
livre 5 ce conflit dans la définition
même de la citoyenneté entre une
définition bourgeoise 1 qui s'impose en
89 une définition populaire qu'on trouve
avec les sans culottes déjà elle
traverse toute notre histoire on la
retrouve en 1848 on la retrouve sur la
commune de paris on la retrouve en 36
avec le front populaire en 68 et ses
aides reçues juste un problème
d'institutions non cdac c'est un
problème de peut-être de voilà
d'inégalités sociales liées au
capitalisme il est économique au sens où
l'économie joue un rôle majeur on le
sait dans dans la dent dans nos dans nos
vies mais c'est aussi un rôle éducatif
de l'éducation l'accès à la et puis des
formes proprement institutionnels oui
c'est ça on est toujours changer aussi
au cours du temps et qui ça peut pas
être la même chose quand vous avez cette
misère on va prendre mais mettons 65
millions de français
c'est une une quantité gigantesque de
personnes éduquées bon ben alors que
vous avez quelqu'un qui rapplique et au
milieu qui dit en une start up il est
coupable
65 millions une personne ne se dirige
pas comme une entreprise
c'est un peuple batailleur et tous les
peuples sont à chacun avec charrie leur
histoire nous à lincoln apprend la
révolution est la creative class avec
obama parce que oui vous dites qu'au
fond macro à fait comme obama voulait
oui c'est sa vision que j'ai analysé
dans la conclusion du livre sont son
programme révolution j'ai essayé de voir
comment il parlait des classes
populaires
c'est fascinant de que n'existe pas
c'est la croyance que tout vient dans le
progrès de l'histoire des élites pour ça
que
j'ai insisté pour montrer que c'est pas
du tout le comme ça que j ai donc dupoux
faut pas s'étonner non plus quand on a
cette vision de l'histoire que
l'histoire se venge comme on dit donc
voila mais il existe des espaces on veut
dire les choses différemment et vous
venez de le faire pendant 50 minutes la
neige en a besoin nous dans la politique
g des 20 dernières années c'était nombre
de gens qui s'intéressait plus à rien
qu'ils lisaient pas les bouquins qui
rencontrait pas alors je vous écrivais
les poissons que j'ai demandé à l'un et
à l'autre comme à chacun de mes invités
de venir avec trois livres qui
augmentait pour vous vos livres de
chevet des livres qui on est ce que
l'homme que vous êtes aujourd'hui ce
sont les derniers qui nous sont tombées
sous la main bah ça c'est vous qui le
dites c'est vous avoir d'autres c'est
comme ça qu'ils interprétaient la
demande qui vous a été faite gérard
noiriel quels sont les livres que vous
avez apporté alors voilà disons que
c'est toujours difficile vainqueur
facile à lire et puis en se disant qu
est-ce qui va marquer et c'est bon bref
puis ce qu'on a sur place parce que les
bibliothèques peuvent être dispersées
qui se tient ce que vous apportez des
exemples donc j'ai voulu aussi un petit
peu montrer la diversité des sources
d'inspiration donc là j'ai pris flora
tristan savez le tour de france voilà
parce que c'est rendre hommage voilà une
militante qui voilà deux étaient
capables de combiner l'engagement
féministe et l'engagement aussi pour
l'émancipation des classes populaires
donc son journal moi c'était au tour de
france qu'elle qu'elle fait partant avec
son regard sur le la folle à la
situation des classes populaires à
l'époque ça s'est terminé sur la
monarchie de juillet jazz à 1134 c'est
une personnalité qu'on a un peu oublié
mais voilà je pense
voilà la vire ce soir ensuite bon j'ai
fait ça dans l'ordre chronologique marc
bloch l'étrange défaite marc bloch c'est
vraiment moi l'historien qui m'a marqué
franchement dans toute mon histoire de
d'historiens je dirais c'est marc bloch
à la fois comme engagement défense de
l'autonomie de la science aussi schéma
blog très important mais aussi résistant
et là n'est pas forcément indépendant de
l'autre
et puis évidemment ce constat qui fait
en 40
c'est l'étrange défaite sur la faillite
des élites est la faillite de la
troisième république c'est aussi je
pense un constat qui n'est pas forcément
éloigné notre situation actuelle
et le dernier c'est rendre hommage à un
sociologue et avec lequel j'ai travaillé
au tout début de ma carrière qui est
décédé maintenant c'est abdelmalek sayad
donc ce monsieur livre la double absence
c'est donc i7 fondateur de la sociologie
d'immigration en france où il montre à
partir du cas algérien les liens entre
immigration immigration
donc ça nous ouvre aussi sur des
questions tout à fait actuelle vers la
question des migrants et sur une manière
de aussi de s'ouvrir sur le monde
voilà pour moi c'est très important
voilà même si j'ai une histoire de
france la question des migrations elle
est extrêmement importante
ce que l'histoire populaire en france
c'est aussi une histoire des migrations
à travers les siècles faut pas l'oublier
c'est cette dimension qui nous relie
aussi à l'universel merci sarah n'a rien
de jean luc mélenchon quels sont les
trois listes a regretté la commande
parce que je suis incapable de dire
parmi les livres mais livrent à fond de
train
je sais pas le faire donc j'ai pris les
trois derniers que qui m'ont marqué que
d'un t2 à côté de mon lit alors il ya
edouard louis alors ça peut paraître peu
mon nom mon ami actuel c'est dans la
littérature c'est bine est un mets et
j'ai rencontré edouard louis et c'est
une rencontre qui m'a illuminé et j'ai
adoré sa manière d'écrire non je lui
raconte tout ça pour dire que quand on a
parlé de son livre il m'a parlé que de
politique mais moi j'aime mieux parler
que de littérature en lui disant que
j'adorais les ruptures de ton de style
les phrases vagues j'ai adoré j'ai adoré
ça se lisait tellement bien alors ça par
contre c'est fondamental non mais donc
là c'est fondamental pour le domaine
kényan moi je suis pas j'ai pas capable
d'écrire aussi bien qu edward oui mais
par contre je peux écrire des choses
politiques alors là c'est fondamental
pour le moment et la pensée alors
pourquoi parce que nous sommes arrivés
maintenant au bout du cycle néolibérale
dans sa violence alors celui là il
rappelle une chose ils enlèvent il donne
un socle anthropologique à notre pensée
de parta jeux il dit depuis toujours
tous les organismes vivants se sont
entraidés et ce sont ceux qui se sont
entraidés s'est démontrée par mille
exemples qui ont survécu et bâti des
sociétés autrement dit madame thatcher
était bien le fauve qu'elle avait l'air
quand elle disait la société n'existe
pas il n'existe que des individus à la
victoire et celui là c'est juste par
clin d'oeil c'est parce que vient de
nous l'offrir et que je le lis tous les
soirs un petit peu j'adore le moment
politique que henry 4 ans au pérou où
ils n'iraient pas dans son propre nom de
l'éthique rappelé en deux mois ce que
c'est la guerre de religion c'est son
regard de type comme ça il y aura mettre
tout ça d'aplomb et puis c'est plus
m'intéresse mais c'est surtout les gens
autour
vous avez des gens fabuleux il ya
montaigne un quinquennat avec quelques
autres et qui disent nous la religion du
roi
c'est pas le sujet le roi c'est le roi
et c'est forcément l'aîné de la branche
aînée c'est comme ça que c'est à dire
que la politique prend le pas sur la
religion sur tout le reste et c'est ça
qui fait la france
on n'a pas parlé de on a évoqué philippe
le bel les filles de plus belle quand le
pape lui dis bien comme c'est moi qui
sait ce que dieu veut
eh bien tu vas faire ce que je te dis et
lui répondra pas du tout moi c'est dieu
qui m'a nommé donc je fais ce que je
veux la loi salique et donc non là
c'était la loi de la séparation le pape
ne commande pas au temporel parce qu'il
commande au spirituel et là on a une
tentative radicalement politico minutes
en désordre inouïe la politique comme
solution au désordre bon ben on arrêtera
france avare pour en parler à cette
parution bouquin qu'il ya eu déjà j'ai
pas de mérite à lui reçoit maintenant
parce que ça fait monter paru mais c'est
super bien écrit bon eh bien cette meute
et merci à tous les deux d'être venu
nous parler de vos livres votre livre
gérard noiriel s'appelle une histoire
populaire de la france de la guerre de
cent ans à nos jours il est disponible
aux éditions agone
on se quitte comme chaque semaine avec
une chanson sur vos bons conseils
aujourd'hui jean-luc mélenchon georges
brassens trompettes de la renommée à
quoi cette chanson parce que je suis
beau et ben alors c'est parti je vivais
à l'écart
de la place publique serein quant à plat
tf1 ténébreux du coliques refusant la
quitter la rançon de la gloire sur
montbrun de lauriers je leur mets comme
un loi les gens de bon conseil ont su me
faire comprendre qu'à l'homme de la rue
j'avais des comptes à rendre et que sous
peine le joueur dans un oubli complet je
devais mettre au grand jour tous mes
petits secrets tempête de la renommée
de bien mal embouchées s'étaient livrés
vous avec le concours du centre national
du livre
[Musique]